[Music]
gentlemen thank first of all
congratulations on the movie thank you
so much for coming in today thank you
very much thank you for inviting us
before we get started
the only reason Collider gets to be at
the Toronto International Film Festival
is because of our great sponsors so I
want to give a huge thank you to
Nordstrom Canada for being a great
sponsor and partnering up with us to
allow us to cover movies and now let's
jump into why I get to talk to you guys
today so first I want to say
congratulations you guys really I
learned a lot about what happened at
that time I felt like I was there
watching these this whole event on you
know unfold talk a little bit about this
is obviously based on what really
happened talk a little bit about trying
to make a movie trying to tell a story
based on real events but also being for
your telling it making a movie so
balancing that line of fact and fiction
and you know telling the story sure so
you know contrary to what people think
is that when you make a movie based on a
true story in a way you are there's less
imagination so to speak it's exactly the
opposite which means you have to find
all the all your imagination all your
inspiration in order to be able to both
be true to the events and making a movie
it has to follow a structure of a movie
and be you know dramatic and interesting
exciting thrilling and all those aspects
within the confinement of a true story
so I think there's a lot of
responsibility involved in that you have
to you know study learn investigate your
subject matter which we did for almost
four years you know on and off intends
two years before we written the script
and you really gotta master your facts
otherwise you know you're you're telling
an untrue story so that's number one and
then how do you do that with dramatic
creating a dramatic structure is just
more challenging completely I just
realized
99% of the people watching this
interview will not have seen the movie
yet so if you don't mind doing the
generic thing could you sort of talk
about what the film is about the film is
about the
the the journey that the deagle Amir
went till he shot it's Halloween and so
the so it's follow his event that
happened and show the whole movie is
from his perspective from his eyes so
most of the time you see what he think
and what he sees what pushed him to do
this this action what influenced him
what polluted him what what he saw what
he feel what he felt what triggered him
to to do this section this awful action
completely one of the things I have to
ask so you obviously you want to act in
as many projects as you can and you get
you find out you go basically it's a
great role for you but you're also
playing a person who did such a heinous
act you know so talk a little bit about
that mentality of this is such a great
role but oh my god this is such a
terrible person it is it's true it's
he's a terrible person but as an actor I
cannot judge him so few facts both first
of all we both Yemenite we both raised
in the same community so I raised under
the values of Torah also I know there we
also like him I raised in a religious
worm Yemenite family and I have the
backgrounds I know I know the prayers
the Yemenite kind of melodies prayers I
know that I had the body language I so I
used to be a religious as well as I when
I was a kid and as you can see I'm not
keeping it that way because because I'm
not it's not my cup of tea and you know
so it was very easy for me to to at the
beginning just to just sink in this and
to wear this character in terms of
emotions and ideologies I needed to
almost turn my skin so I because I'm I'm
not saying I I needed to adjust the way
that I the way that I think in order to
think
as like him so it was pretty easy at the
beginning because I'm because I'm coming
from the same background but in terms of
the emotions that I need to to to to
feel in order to to be faithful to the
story and to be faithful for the for the
character it was extremely hard at the
beginning but your own gave me the
opportunity to do the method acting and
and I was I completely trust him on this
on this journey no come on you did a
great job one of the things that I yeah
one of the things I took away from the
from the film is that it it feels to me
like a lot of people this whole thing
had been boiling up and it seems like a
lot of people maybe knew that this could
happen what what was like some of the
stuff that maybe you learned while
researching this that really surprised
you yeah so what was surprising again by
I knew I mean I lived through that
period I was part of that period I was
part of the pro peace movement at the
time but we were not aware of couple of
things one of them is like how strong
and why the opposition was and they hate
the level of a the politics of hate that
was going on you know sort of labeling
gates Hawk Robin as a traitor
and creating him as a demon a demon and
eventually all that led to you know deal
legitimize him and making him a person
that by you know shooting him killing
him taking him out is actually a heroic
act to do so there was a whole pressure
around that that was boiling for maybe
half of the people yeah that's the
shocking part that we saw it was in
front of the eyes we also have
responsibility for not protecting him
not that that's you know the main issue
here at all but they should have been
more protection for Robin because of
this noises or violence that were
drumming completely um no matter what
movie you're making there's never enough
time and there's never enough money so
before the you start filming for both of
you what were you really
to be able to accomplish with the
limitations in front of you and I guess
it also applies for you yeah for me I
mean is you know as a director as a
writer
I mean co-writer is a producer also for
me you know financing a movie of that
sort was very very difficult regardless
because you know the story the subject
matter is very controversial in Israel
some of the criticism towards people
today around the government and our
important personalities in Israeli
society and when you do that it's
difficult so for example we didn't get
film funds support it means Republic
film funds which usually is very
difficult if almost impossible to make a
movie without that so we managed to
overcome that by you know there were
certainly individuals that you know came
to the rescue and helped us make this
movie so that was like on a very basic
level and then when you go through you
know your research meeting people
there's certain resentments that you
have to overcome you know just by the
fact that you're researching people that
are criticized in the movie so that was
very difficult but in terms of
accomplishing for me it was more on a
level of artistic level meaning that the
movie will it will shake you when you
watch it and afterwards because what
happens is it you know the the actual
events took place 24 years ago and for
us it's like yesterday it's actually
today we're talking about now
you know attacking democracy is now it's
relevant this moment shooting a prime
minister shooting a president in the USA
that's the equivalent is an attack on
democracy right it's like you choose a
government and then somebody's trying to
attack a kill democracy so and we see it
right now as we speak in many many
places around the world so for me the
important part was that when you have a
memory of something you know slowly but
surely it dissipates and becomes some
kind of a just a word the concept as
opposed to the strong emotions that are
associated with it the the power of the
trauma so I want to us to relive the
trauma as a community be able to look at
the trauma in the eyes and maybe go back
there
figure out you know what happened why it
happened what can we learn out of this
experience and move forward in you know
to a better future so deaths was for me
the major challenge so that the movie
will not be like okay I watched it
somebody died oh you know it's very sad
but it's just another movie about
somebody who did certain things and died
I wanted to be you know that experience
and to create that was the whole journey
of you know six years of work yeah all
that research and everything you did
really shows on the screen I'll say it's
one of the best things I've seen this
year thank you so really I think you
guys did a tremendous job with it but
you talked about the challenges yeah the
challenge for me was to be to be
faithful for the for this specific
character even though I hate what he did
even though I am NOT I'm not I don't
think the same as him of course but for
me it was to to be able to and it was
surprising for me also to to to go
through this journey and to feel and see
the depth that I'm going to that I'm
that I'm finding in myself in in terms
of emotions and so I really wanted to
and I really wanted to to be and think
as him as hard as it can be but I think
that I'm okay with with the result and I
I had Johan Silverman which which I
trust I trusted the whole through the
whole journey and that was the main
challenge for me sure no allow me just
to say something about you that because
he can't say it about himself but when I
met him you know during the audition the
pier at the beginning I met a guy was
the closest to a hippie he's very hippie
you know I going to a part is also love
cacao who think parties the Peruvian
costumes and he was really out there and
during the process he became a religious
like an Orthodox Jew keeping all the
traditions to a level where in Judaism
you're not allowed to touch unless it's
your wife you
cannot touch a woman a woman cannot
touch amendment cannot that woman unless
it's your wife
so there's through Mary you have to
marry in order to do this okay and he
became religious and suddenly from one
day to another he doesn't you know shake
the hands of the producers no you know
production managers there's just nothing
he's like looking at them they you know
she can't but say good morning which you
know Israelis are very tough you know
sure physic very physical people and so
they want know like you don't suddenly
he became religious for us and it
allowed him to also you know get into
the part and become the assassin sure
yeah I went I just want to add to this I
went to to the synagogue three times a
day put feeling and everything and I
kept Shabbat and I love to do things on
Shabbat and so for almost five months I
think I was completely religious and and
that's the man who pushed me to do this
and and to be religious I didn't think
that ever in my life I will wear it
succeed or a key power or wear this kind
of a character and I have to ask you
what is it when you do something
full-throttle like that
I've spoken actors that have done some
stuff like that and they talk about the
decompression process that it's you know
you wrap on the film and then it's the
next day
and then it's just mentally who are you
again it's it's about finding yourself
after this endeavor so talk a little bit
about what happened after you rapped
okay so I have a story about it because
in the rough party Yoann so through the
whole journey through the whole
rehearsals and shooting you know on just
divided me and he he kept me and he we
were thought we were thinking as ego
thought okay and he didn't he didn't
express his own ideas or his own
ideology about the whole thing he was
just like we went we were directly to
this till the end but at the begin and
then in the raw party he said what do
you think about this this act this act
and about what he did and I was like
thinking okay it's weird it's real to me
well how come that okay something
changed
I add just myself so much till I was I
thought this is the right thing to do so
the at that moment not to worry
yeah he was convinced murdering robbing
is the right thing to do
get the neck toys there's an area
completely so into the character and
then I realized when he said that I
realized okay I need help i need help
with with with taking this character off
off of me
yeah and I I went to a few therapists
like energetic kind of a therapist and I
went to Thailand just two four three
four three weeks to recover and to just
forget the whole thing I was like I I
did it I'm I was I talk I I told myself
that I want to forget what happened I
don't want to any any of his energy to
exist in my in my body I have to ask you
were you nervous when you're sitting
there in Thailand Thailand you trying to
decompress are you scared that he's
gonna call you and say we need to do
three days gonna happen was one day
there was one day but that day was very
simple for him it was just like
technical stuff you know writing some
scripture sure taking it putting the gun
out of his you know right yeah I knew I
couldn't bring him back you can't bring
that back what happened with this guy he
became the assassin in such a way that
as I said we had a deal
the contract was from before the
shooting months before the shoot until
the wrap party the deal was that I'm
with him one percent which means I will
never talk about the assassination as a
bad thing like me and him I'm like
pushing him to do it and I'm helping him
becoming strong in faith that one has to
do it only to help him do his job the
best way I could which is as an actor is
to become the
the assassin right together becoming
allomere that was my old job so he never
heard my opinion about the subject to a
matter where at some point he thought
maybe I'm making this movie to show that
it was good and even even push as like
people yeah I will let anybody anybody
crew anyone in Israel you know there's
such a resentment towards the murderer
but everybody wanted to say something I
told the entire crew director
photography production designer
they just know where he should not know
that there's a world that is opposed to
the murder just let him be myself and it
I think it gave him that freedom at the
end of the line completely I completely
got it so obviously you must have shown
the film when it was done to friends and
family you're done like a test screening
so I'm curious what did you learn from
those early screenings that impacted the
finished film and and when did you see
the film for the first time okay the
first time okay the first time that I
saw we said we said in in a you know in
the office of he's working on a new TV
show in Israel and so we sat in this
office in front of a TV and I saw the
movie for two hours and I was shocked I
couldn't even say anything after two
hours we went to drink after after we
saw after I saw the movie first
for the first time and I just told that
I I have nothing I have nothing nothing
to say it's that you just like give me a
such a strong punch in my stomach and it
turns my emotions even though I was
surprising to to see that that I didn't
see myself as as an actor I didn't see
myself there and I couldn't even accept
that it's me it wasn't me
so and where I wanted to go with this
and so yeah continue yeah so I'm just
about this particular occasion so at
some point I decided to show to the
actors to the cast lead cast the movie
and that's why and I said it's not fair
for Yuda to see the first time even with
the other casts
because you know he's in every frame of
the movie and that's why we said okay
I'm not gonna let you see it on a big
screen before the rest of the cast but
you'll see it privately in a large TV
set so that you know so it's not your
first time you already I realize you
know you have a feel for the movie
so that's what happened was really
really shocking on the second screen
when Dahlia went Wow let me tell this
okay so on that so here's the first
screening for for the cast which is
always shocking forecasts they see
themselves and especially in this case
such controversial and ade hated people
and they represent them on screen it's
it's a big deal
so at that event we decided that also
the daughter of it's Huckabee in prime
minister chakra being I mean the late I
mean she'll also attend to she arrived
with her daughter to see together with
him so if you have like the actor who
plays the assassin with the daughters
written order of it's like I've been
really wild so there's this screaming
and we're sitting and it's tense and I
don't know what's gonna happen because
if she comes against the movie you know
it's not sure I know and it was the
first time that I realized that what I
did I mean that it's it's a story it's
it's a real story and I just when she
when they were there I realized that oh
my god
I'm playing the guy who killed her
father and then I started to cry and
then I went outside I ran outside when I
couldn't see the last scene and I went
outside I just started to cry you know I
went to them and I cried and he said I'm
sorry it wasn't me it wasn't me it
wasn't me so the movie ended and she was
you know crying throughout the movie of
course and then she said some nice
superlative you know she really really
appreciated the movie and then the
second thing she did was to run looking
for him and to hug him and thank him for
being so authentic you know for
portraying the assassin in such an
authentic way she actually they hugged
and cried two of them which was so
moving and also closure
the process is not closed you because
you know yet the world needs to see the
movie but was a closure for the
production I do want to ask you before
you showed it to and I want to ask yeah
I want to say something sure
so I had a couple of screening which you
have to do because they need to get
feedback and also when only when you
watch it with the audience
you realize certain things as a director
you have to do it so anyway I showed it
in the US and I decided to make a
screening to all my friends and friends
of friends that are not Jewish and not
Israeli so they'll have nothing to do
with the story on an emotional level
they're just gonna watch a movie like
movie which I cannot watch it that way
and the interesting part was and
especially it's New York City so it's
really international and what we saw is
that people were thought that it's about
their country like we had two Indian
friends they said it's it's about our
country right now this is what we are
going through and then the French talked
about you know how it is the attention
the religious tension and the
nationalistic tension is exactly what
they're going through this moment and
every person from every country not to
mention they the New Yorkers that we're
talking about Donald Trump of course and
you know the nationalistic sentiments
incitement all over the place and I
think what the movie also shows and it
was very important to show and that's
what I realize how one-to-one it is
during the research is that you have a
leader he says something that something
translate into action of violence he
says this guy is a traitor
the next thing you know that traitor is
being attacked physically or in this
case being shot and you see one-to-one
how it works and you can also see that
in the u.s. you see Donald Trump coming
out with like anti immigration the other
day and then you see Jews getting shot
in a synagogue because they supported
immigrants it's like one-to-one it's so
simple that it's painful it's painful to
say I don't want to I don't want to
bring in my politics to this internet
anyway I'll just say F Trump I need to
I'm sorry my strong strong opposition to
that man
yeah so I'm almost out of time but I
have to ask you you're doing it's been
seven years since the late court
which I also thought was so well done
I'm so happy to hear you doing something
else right now what can you tease people
about this miniseries you're working on
it's a TV mini-series eight episodes
about the arguably the most traumatic
war in Israel history called the Yom
Kippur War which happened in October
1973 I'm telling the story of the first
three days which were shocking because
Israel was attacked from Syria on the
north and the south from Egypt and was
there was that danger of extinction
extinction of being occupied and this
traumatic three days are what I'm
telling through the eyes of you know
tank unit soldiers in her more which is
our North the most North and northern
part of Israel etc etc so it's it's a
really war story well one is so basic
basically what he does
so you're gone came to Israel to do to
touch the most fragile topics in in this
country and run away nothing right
everybody you know he's he's got the
nerve to do that yet listen I it takes
balls of steel to touch this enemy I
didn't want to say anybody know it's one
of the things though is one of the
things why your film is so good is
because it felt so authentic and when
you're dealing with subject matter like
those three days how much research had
bitten you've been doing and how much
are you sort of making sure that
everything you're portraying is like as
realistic as it can be yes so this
particular the new project is 10 years
of research it's not research that I did
it's the first time I'm directing a
movie did not right although by now I
rewrote so much of it that I'm co-writer
as well but I met I met the people it's
big it's inspired by real people I met
all of them I went on location to really
go through the combats that they were
taking part in spoke to people who were
you know that's their stories and when I
got all that stuff I changed the script
accordingly make sure that it's
authentic I'm bringing
on set experts that were taking part of
these combats so I'm trying to make it
as authentic as I can but but at the end
of the day it's all about the approach
with the actors to be honest it's also
with with this gentleman it's it's about
you know tuning to the essence of what
happened there and being able to portray
that that gives the feeling of
authenticity more than although I can
very pedantic about historical facts at
the same time it's more about the
essence of you know the presence like
telling it in a truthful true way as
opposed to mannerism you know acting yes
you know sort of large acting it's more
about taking all the guards down and
just telling it like we speak now
completely can what's the title
it's called valley of tears valley of
tears so when will it be on TV in Israel
probably in six to nine months got it
does it have a plan for an American
release of course I mean not a plan but
that's they call it talks about taking
I'm looking forward to seeing it thank
you very much I mean it you guys did a
tremendous job with this he's very much
very powerful film I hope it's a huge
success for you guys and thank you so
much for coming in the studio thank you
so much